welcome back now we may be leaving
afghanistan but quietly under the radar
america is returning to libya
even though we pulled all of our
diplomats out in 2014
america still has the bad taste of
benghazi in our mouths
but joe biden doesn't care according to
reports his administration
is considering reopening our embassy in
tripoli
so how are things going in libya right
now well a report in march by um panel
of experts described a free-for-all
inside the country as foreign powers
flying drones
transport aircraft surface-to-air
missiles artillery and armored vehicles
as well as mercenaries from chad sudan
and syria what could possibly go wrong
joining me now
republican congressman from ohio jim
jordan and
the judiciary committee ranking member
congressman
i ask you that question seriously what
could go wrong
again yeah well we know what went wrong
back on september 11 2012 and we know
how the
then obama administration tried to blame
it on a video and cover it up and
remember
we had chris stevens sean smith glen
doherty and tyrone woods give their life
for our country
and frankly lawrence while tyrone woods
was still fighting on the roof of the
annex
protecting himself defending his fellow
citizens the
clinton state department was already
trying to blame it on a video
and of course susan rice went on uh went
on the sunday shows a few days after
that
and and made that same argument misled
the entire country that somehow it was
the video that was the catalyst for this
so
i don't really know why we're heading
back i mean when i talk with folks
around our district they're not talking
about
getting american presence back in libya
they're talking about
you know the crisis on the border
they're talking about the fact that
crime is up because democrats defund the
police they're talking about the fact
that
price of everything inflation is driving
the price of everything up
and they're talking about the fact that
employee employers can't find employees
because joe biden keeps paying people
not to work you know congressman we tend
to forget things so we got some video
of when you were on the committee
talking to the former secretary take a
look
you had three options secretary
you could tell the truth tell him it was
a terrorist attack
you could say you know what we're not
quite sure
don't don't really know for sure i don't
think the evidence is
you pick the one with no evidence and
you did it because
libya was supposed to be as mr roston
pointed out this great success story for
the obama white house and the
clinton state department congressman i
think that's the same shirt and tight
that you have on right now
it may may have been um but you know it
was
the reason they did it was 56 days
before an election
and they wanted to admit that they
misled the american people and they
blamed this thing on a video and it
you know you think about what tyrones
did for our country the sacrifice he
made protecting his fellow citizens
and that not even within 24 hours did
anyone get there
no one was sent to help these people and
now we're going to go back into this
country where we know there's chaos
there's been chaos there
for i don't know how many years now so
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to
me i don't think it makes a whole lot of
sense to the american people
particularly when they see the things
that i talked about this this chaos on
our southern border
the fact that when you defund the police
you get an increase in crime in every
major city we're seeing that
and the price of lawrence the price of
everything is up right now price of
lumber price of steel price of aluminum
price of copper
price of eggs milk bread beef and not to
mention the price of gasoline
and yet the biden administration is
focused on going back maybe it has
something to do with susan rice i don't
know she was the person who went on the
five sunday shows
five days after that terrible day when
four americans lost their lives
of course she's a big policy advisor to
president by now i don't know why
they're doing it but it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to me and my guess is
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
to the american people you know i was
reading this this is from the libyan
envoy they said there is now willingness
of the u.s administration
to exert pressure and invest political
capital with some of the allies who have
been interviewed
and were a part of the problem in libya
that was not the case
during the trump administration what's
your reaction to that
all i know is during the trump
administration we didn't have thousands
of rockets being fired on our ally
israel we didn't have our secretary of
state treated like
secretary blinken was treated up in
alaska by his chinese counterpart that
would have never happened to mike pompeo
in a trump administration
president trump projected strength the
the rest of the world our adversaries
understood that
we're not seeing that now so i mean
we'll see how this shakes out
but i got my concerns and my guess is uh
there's a lot of folks who have who
share those concerns about this
this move to get back into libya i don't
understand why we start
continue to get into these international
conflicts and when we have a true
ally we can't stand with them i think
that shows you
where this administration is going
congressman thank you so much for coming
on
you bet thank you all right biden
refused to answer a lot of questions
during his presidency hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else